- [Instructor] You have a government
and you also have the
people that are governed,
and in previous videos,
we talked about this idea
of linkage institutions,
which are institutions
that connect the government to the people
and the people to the government
so people know what's
going on in the government
and so that the government
knows the preferences
of the people.
And examples of linkage institutions,
let me just draw an arrow here,
examples of
linkage institutions
might be elections where
the people are able
to communicate their preferences,
parties where that could
obviously influence elections,
but also influence policies.
You have various interest groups,
but what we're gonna focus on
in this video is the media.
Now, there's one pure view of the media
and sometimes it's
called the fourth estate
where it has a central role in government,
where the goal is to hold
the government accountable,
to inform the people, to
have this pure objective view
of what is going on with the government
and bring it to the people
and then help the people hold
the government accountable,
and also help the
government know objectively
what the people are thinking.
And that is an idea that many
in the media may strive for,
but you have to think about,
what are the incentives?
What makes the media relevant
and how do they exist?
Most media outlets are
for-profit organizations
and so, let me make a few of these.
Let's say that we have
this one right over here.
I'll call this media outlet one.
Let me do this one right over here,
let's call this media outlet two.
As for-profit organizations,
they need to get revenue
so they can get their profit somehow,
and for most of them, it
comes through ad revenue.
So, those ad dollars that
are shown during the news
or during a TV show.
And so, you might guess that,
hey, if I need to get ad revenue,
advertisers aren't going to
wanna show ads on a station
that's not getting any viewership,
so they're going to say,
hey, how do we get maximum viewership?
One argument might be, hey, we
wanna be the most objective,
high-quality news source,
and that is a strategy
that could be approached,
or they could say, hey,
maybe I could cater
to certain belief systems,
to, maybe, left-leaning
folks or right-leaning folks.
If you were to say that
this is the distribution
of people in our
population right over here
where people on this side lean left
and then people on the
right side right over here
lean to the right, and
these are people in between,
there absolutely is a strategy
where maybe if you are
this media outlet, you say,
hey, I wanna be centrist.
Maybe give equal time,
equal views to either side
and maybe I get that viewership.
But you could also have a strategy,
well, what if I wanna
capture all of these folks?
Well, what they might
wanna hear is something
that's more critical of the right,
that reinforces their left beliefs
and so I could cater to that.
Similarly, you might have
something on the right saying,
I could capture all of this audience here
by helping, to some degree, telling them
what they want to hear,
and maybe in some level,
reinforcing their beliefs.
But by doing that, I get a large audience
and I'm able to sell a lot of ads.
It's an interesting
debate whether it is good
or bad that you have these media outlets
that might cater to certain ideologies,
but even if they are,
they're still performing
the role on some level
as a linkage institution.
Because these folks are trying to cater
and understand what
their viewership wants,
that is a signal to the government that,
okay, at least the demographic
that watches media station one,
this is the kind of stuff
they're thinking about.
And the demographic that
watches media station two,
these are the things that
they are thinking about.
So, it does communicate,
in some way, to government,
but you could imagine, almost
every media outlet is trying
to market that they are
that ideal objective.
And here's an example of that
where a media outlet is
actually reporting on
how non-objective other media
outlets are in their opinion
or perhaps in the
opinion of their viewers.
- Tonight, a fair and balanced examination
of the mainstream media's bias
with three glaring new examples.
First up, Donald Trump is firing
back at the Washington Post after learning
the paper's devoted an army of 20 staffers
to dig up dirt on every
nook and cranny of his life.
- [Instructor] Now, another
dimension to appreciate
how the media, as a linkage institution,
might influence government,
or frankly, might influence
other linkage institutions
like elections, is how
they report on things.
Remember, they're trying to get viewership
because the viewership is
what makes the advertisers
wanna advertise on their media outlets,
and so, to get viewership, one strategy is
to make things really exciting.
Make it look like a sports competition,
make it look like a horse race.
And you see this,
especially during elections,
that oftentimes the focus may
not even be on the substance,
it's really on who's
leading at a given time.
That can sometimes influence the election
and give that person
extra momentum regardless
of what their actual positions are.
And here is an example of that.
- Hillary Clinton is extending her lead
over Donald Trump in
several national polls.
CNN is releasing a
brand new poll of polls,
which is an average of the six
last surveys and it shows Donald Trump
trailing Hillary Clinton by 10 points,
so how does he close that gap?
- [News Anchor] Donald Trump's reached
new heights in the latest Fox News poll.
With 39% of Republicans nationwide,
he's more than doubling Ted Cruz at 18.
Marco Rubio and Ben
Carson are virtually tied
for third within the
poll's margin of error.
- [Instructor] So, the media,
definitely a very important
linkage institution in our society,
but it's really interesting
to think about the
various incentives for it
and how that might influence its actions
as a linkage institution
and how its motivations might even affect
other linkage institutions like elections.